la première de toutes les sociétés de
chemin de fer la sncf procède
actuellement à l'étude de l'utilisation
d'un équipement électronique pour la
réservation des places tous ceux qui ont
l'habitude de louer leur place dans le
train connaissent ces images d'attentats
un guichet derrière lequel un préposé
téléphone pour retenir une place dans un
train déterminer actuellement ces
opérations se font manuellement à l'aide
de schémas sur lesquels les places
retenues sont inscrits autant de schéma
qu'il y a deux trains dans une journée
et cela x 30 ou 31 puisque les locations
peuvent être faites
un mois al avance
toutes ces opérations manuelles seront
supprimés lorsque serait étendu le
système utilisé pour meuf trains de la
ligne paris lille tourcoing
grâce à un ordinateur électronique au
guichet l'employé dispose d'un clavier
permettant de composer les désirs de
l'usagé choix du train de la place côté
couloir aux vitres sens de la marche ou
non compartiment fumeurs ou non
réservations au wagon restaurant 28
secondes plus tard le ticket de
réservation est délivrée par la machine
si le choix d'une place déterminée ne
peut être satisfait la machine choisit
la place se rapprochant le plus du désir
formuler si le train est complet elle
l'indiquent naturellement 10 postes
l'interrogation existe ainsi à la gare
du nord et dans les villes desservies
par les trains de la ligne paris-lille
la mémoire de l'ordinateur que l'on va
voir dans un instant permis de porter à
deux mois les possibilités de
réservation et de donner toutes les
combinaisons possibles de location sur
le parcours aller et retour enfin cet
ordinateur donne périodiquement l'état
des réservations prévient lorsque 1% a
choisi est atteint et effectue toutes
les opérations comptables et
statistiques
un pas vers la simplification est en
train de s'accomplir